there's more one way to cook an egg as
they say and similarly there's more than
one way to suppress the vote or suit or
to suppress a census and Republicans
have been caught kind of doing all of
the above and just being generally
misleading Republicans have been sending
fundraising letters with bogus push poll
surveys disguised as official census
documents the census is actually about
to start 2020 is a census year we've
covered for years that the census is
really important it determines how all
sorts of different funds are distributed
to States congressional districts it
determines how representation is doled
out in the United States and the census
has been a fiasco under Donald Trump
there were periods of totally absent and
no leadership it's been underfunded
behind on hiring poor execution there is
now someone running the census we'll
hear from them momentarily and now
Republicans send this via the mail a
letter called 2020 congressional
district census now of course they don't
say this is the US Census they call it
the congressional district census but
very reasonable people might not realize
that the census is all federal that the
term congressional census doesn't really
make sense that this is something else
and this is the point it is a section
for political profile asking for example
do you plan to support Donald Trump in
the 2020 presidential election that's
not a real question you would see on an
actual census it asks whether political
correctness has gotten out of hand in
America hint
that's not a real census question and it
also includes at the bottom a box to
certify the survey which of course has
no real meaning whatsoever other than to
make this bogus document appear more
legitimate than it is and then there's
also a spot to put in your credit card
number and send a donation to the
Republican National Committee this is
what we call push questions these are
opinions presented to you as questions
these have been spotted around the
country Ohio has reported them
Washington and California they've been
seen in Montana this has been done
before by
back in 2010 there was actually
legislation passed called the prevent
deceptive census look-alike mailings Act
it's SiC that we need that but we do and
what that act did was to ban
non-government groups from sending
anything with the word census on the
envelope cover or wrapper through the
mail
now this mailing because of how it was
packaged may not violate that act and
that means that the Act is not nearly
specific and strict enough here is
congresswoman Katey Porter questioning
the census director about it this is
Steven Dillingham he's sort of open to
investigating this but he keeps talking
about how the senate census generally
handles investigations and Katey Porter
keeps repeating okay yeah but I want to
talk about this letter from Republicans
not generally what you do take a look at
the video but here we are ten years
later and the RNC is at it again
dr. Dillingham are you familiar with
this RNC mailer I've heard generally
about them about the problem have you
seen it we have sent it to the Census to
the postal bureau for investigation will
you please commit to reviewing this we
will be glad to review it yeah I'm
asking you personally will you commit to
reviewing this I certainly will thank
you have you asked the RNC to cease and
desist from using the term 2020 census
or official census in its mailings
congresswoman I would have to look and
see I'm not sure who sent that out and I
am okay because wait because I have
reading glasses
see this way down here on page two this
little bitty box and about I would say
four to six point font it says paid for
by the Republican National Committee
will you ask the RNC to stop using the
terms 2020 census official census and a
registration census code we will we will
study this problem in let me tell you
what we do
avoiding any type of scam or mystery I
would I would love to ask you more
generally about this but I'm concerned
about this and this mailing has already
gone out this of course is Donald
Trump's pick to run the census this does
appear to be a difference between
Democrats and Republicans I was not able
to find any instances of Democrats
sending fundraising letters that are
designed to look like the census to
trick people and they're still playing
this game so many Americans have moved
on to how do we get health care because
our system is broken how do we solve our
crumbling infrastructure while
curtailing spending on bombs and
missiles all over the world how do we
get a president who won't be a worldwide
embarrassment day in and day out and
meanwhile Republicans are using their
same old tricks and the tricks work
voter suppression voter purges
fundraising letters meant to look like
the census with the word census on them
in a sense this year in spite of being
just push poll questions meant to get
people to favor Donald Trump and maybe
even cut a check or put in their credit
card number to donate to the RNC and
unfortunately I wish I could say this
stuff doesn't work but it does if you
receive this you are more likely to
think I did the census when the actual
census forms show up this stuff is
likely to have all sorts of follow-on
effects and this stuff again it should
be against the law it seems as though
they figured out a way to get around
that act that prevents impersonating
census documents but these are the
tricks that have worked for them for a
very long time and these are the tricks
that they're going to continue using
unless somebody stops them and so far
it's not clear that at least in any kind
of quick and rapid sense this is going
to be stopped check this out right now
for 20 bucks david pakman show viewers
can get an entire year of award-winning
antivirus plus a VPN which makes you
anonymous online and you can use both on
three of your devices when you use the
link down below it's all provided by our
sponsor total AV total AV is an
antivirus company that has earned their
excellent reputation I use it to keep my
computer and phone safe it works on
Windows Mac I
phone Android even tablets these days if
you're using the internet on any device
without a layer of protection you're
taking a risk
total AV protects you from viruses
spyware ransomware adware these are real
threats that can create real problems
for devices that get infected maybe you
got a new computer or phone over the
holidays that's not yet protected maybe
you have devices that have been
vulnerable for even longer than that
some people aren't even aware that
they've been infected it's not worth
taking the risk when it's this
affordable to defend your devices total
AV is giving my viewers 80% off so for
just 20 bucks you're going to get a
whole year of totally these premium
antivirus on three devices plus you're
going to get their trusted VPN that
makes you anonymous when browsing online
and has a bunch of security and privacy
benefits it's so simple to use you
install it it runs in the background you
forget about it it's 20 bucks very well
spent when you think about the peace of
mind that comes with it check out total
AV click the link right underneath this
video